[Music]
welcome everybody
my name
is casper and i am a senior manager for
program applications at thermal fusion
scientific
so we all know that we're still emerging
from the kovid19 pandemic and its impact
on all areas of life and health is still
being felt around the world so today
we'll discuss the impact of the pandemic
on hiv care and treatment
and how we can get back on track to
achieving the unh 2030 targets will hear
perspectives from brazil
from nigeria
south africa
and from uganda
so just before we
go ahead i will just remind everyone
about the unh target and how we got here
today
in 2016
countries around the world agreed to
achieve or to walk towards the fast
track
target of 1990 by 2020 and this meant
that by 2020 90 percent of people
living with hiv would know their status
90
of those who were diagnosed with hiv
infection would receive sustained
antiretroviral therapy and 90 of those
who are receiving antiretroviral therapy
would achieve viral suppression
in addition to that there will be 500
000 fewer infections
um fewer new hiv infections as well as
zero discrimination so the 2020 targets
were a preamble to the 2030 target
and the twin phase target was to end the
epi the epidemic of hiv aids um as part
of the unaids
the sustainable development goals
basically go free
so if we look at where we are today
globally in terms of our progress
towards this target
we would remember that kobe 19 began at
the end of 2019 and by the end of 2020
these were the
the progress that the world had made in
terms of the 1990 targets and we see
that we
missed this
2020 1990 targets where 84 of people
living with hiv knew their status by
2020 and this left more than 27 of
people living with hiv who were not on
treatment and roughly about a third with
unsuppressed viral loads
and une's report
says that these gaps are even larger for
subpopulations of children
young people and men
so today we're gonna hear from
we're going to hear from four speakers
who are representatives of their
countries and they're going to talk
about the impact of the pandemic on this
1990 target and hiv drug as a sense in
their countries and in their regions
they're going to
tell us about some practices that were
implemented to deal with the
disruption of care and treatment during
the pandemic and we'll also discuss some
key transferable lessons that were
learnt
in this countries and as countries look
beyond kobe 19
who was achieving the 95 95 95 2030
targets what can be done and what can be
adopted across the world
and um
just disclose that all speakers at
staten in today's symposium where
provided an honorarium by thermal fisher
for their participation today
and without further ado i'll introduce
the speakers to us today
and we're going to be hearing first from
professor carlos brita
dr brutus is a professor of infectious
diseases
at the school of medicine at federal
university of bahia in brazil dr british
has been involved in several clinical
trials and hiv and has co-authored over
190 census papers
he was the editor-in-chief of the
brazilian journal of infectious diseases
from 20 2009 to 2016
and he's an editorial board member of
current hiv research journal and so
without further ado i invite professor
um carlos to give us this
presentation you
obi
me i have next slide please
first i i thank the organizers for the
opportunity to share some data on
the impact of copied 19
on hiv care in brazil this is my
conflict of interest
next please
i will start the presentation showing
that the number of people
living with hiv
linked to care
they could increase it from 2019 to 2021
as you can see in the right side of the
slide
however
the number of dispensational the number
of uh
drugs delivered for
such patients
decreasing the same period of time from
almost 5 million dollars is to
about below 4 million dollars it is a
probably an impact of the coffee
pandemic
making some people unable to take the
medication to go to the pharmacy to
review the prescription
and on the right in the left side you
can see the the number of alphabet in
brazil we had over 30 million cases with
over
66 uh
664 000 people dead
and the key with me is a nice dance pair
100 000 14.5
next please
handle
next slide please
uh
one way to look at the numbers and see
how they did pandemic affect the hiv
care excuse me one slide
behind
what is to evaluating the number of
tests that were performed for follow-up
of hiv patients
this light before this would show
yes
here you can see in the upside of the
slide the number of cd4 sales count be
formed during the pandemic and you can
see uh
in the dark blue
a sharp decrease in the number of tests
performing on april for maybe
2020 until the end of the year and the
same would be observed for our viral hiv
viral rule before and in brazil that
year we see that uh in 2020 there was a
partial hint over the numbers but the
numbers still are below that observed in
2019 next one please
next slide please
it seems there is a yeah
this picture showed the number of people
started hydro biotherapy during during
the pandemic period and again we see in
the dark blue a decrease a sharp
decrease in the number of people i
started heterovirus therapy if you
compare 2020 to 2019
and again i slightly his recovery of
their numbers in 2021 but they are still
below that observed in 2019 and prepping
them to pay you the next piece
and
this impact can be
also observed in the number of
new hiv case reported by the brazilian
means of health over time
we see a decrease in the number from
2017 to 2019
but
it is more market uh from 2019 to 2002
entity if and if you
expand the numbers observing 2021 up to
the
june
we see that
it
will give us a total of about 8 000
people new case diagnosing that period
of time which means half of those
observed and uh detected in
2018 2019
it means a a potential impact on the
first to 95
target or nades because the number of
new cases are decreasing over time
next slide please
we can see now so another effect of the
pandemic in the
delay in our
review in patients comparing the
pre-pandemic and the duty pandemic video
in 2019 only 40 percent of people
on untethered virus therapy had a delay
higher than not 30 days in receiving the
antithrow viral drugs in 2020 there was
an increase in 24 25 in this number it
means that 18 of people living with hiv
on antihetrovirus therapy had a delay
uh higher than uh 30 days you have
feeling the hetero viral drugs nexus
like this
this can show up one way the brazilians
of hell tried to minimize this problem
at the beginning before the pandemic
period we had most of the people 72
percent uh had a review of untethered
drugs up to
30 days
and then it was increasing to uh
almost
60
and in 2021 only 40 percent of people
took the tetra viral drugs for a shorter
period of time most of them received for
two or three months it means less
need to go to the
health therapy to take the drugs and
would improve the
adults of people
to therapy next time please next slide
please
the same profile this important of a
decrease in the number of cases we can
see for prepping for the exposure
prophylaxis dispensing during pandemic
we see again that 2020 was the most
affected year and there is a coincidence
of the peak of the
the case you can see the figure below
and uh they decrease the sharper
decrease in the number of people taking
drugs for prevention during that period
of time
next please
here we can see the proportion of people
studying therapy with a cd4 counting
over
500 cells
and the proportion of viral suppression
regarding the number of people is
starting therapy early in the day the
course of disease there was a stability
over time
and we can see the same in the number of
proportions the proportion of people
wanting on ant heterobiotherapy
presenting with viral suppression except
for
uh decrease that is perceivable from
2018 to 2021 among women we know that
women are more vulnerable and uh
for uh it has more they have more
problems growing up adherence to therapy
and uh it seems that the economy
affected in a unequal way of men and
women regarding viral suppression next
slide please
the idea is
however seems to be
on the rising that the
last three years you can see that from
2019 to 2021 the numbers
show an increase in the advance rate as
well as they lasted to follow up was uh
decreasing over time
and we can see that according to the
official data the patient the
proportional patient equity address was
higher in the last three years next
please
next slide
here we can see the proportion of people
lost to follow up by hearing sex and
again we have one stability from 2018
2021 2019 and 2021 showing that uh
probably the impact of the pandemic on
this specific aspect were not
that important at least for
on the official data next like this
we can see also this important
irritation in care by uh
sex engaging them over time
from 2016 to 2019 we have an increase in
the tissue in care and uh
for a women
women and men and in general population
living with hiv and it is stable in 2012
we have no data from 2021 but probably
there is no significant change in this
period of time next slide please
here
we we try to see uh to evaluate how the
pandemic affect our patients in our aids
clinic
and here you can see that the first
the first case of uh coffee it was a
technic february
2018 by year so we have an increase a
peak of a
missing medical visit in the next two or
three months
and again
it decrease over time but still remain
high
until november when the number of the
pandemic became
uh lesser than in the previous months
and uh in 2021
we have an oscillation but again when
the pandemic peaks in august september
we have an increase in the number of the
proportion of patients missing medical
visit which of course is has a direct
impact on our dnac in such population
next slide please
we try to look at the uh reasons for
missing schedule medical visiting during
almost 40 percent of patients reported
missing medical vision during pandemic
failure and the main reason for doing
that was
a fear of complete contamination
future double patient did not show up
because they are afraid of our
contamination by providing this
period of upon them
next slide please
some additional fines
we noted an increasing number of this
medical within the first month 2021 22
not capitulated by official report yet
as well as an increase in the number of
administration that stopped therapy
during profit 19 related factors
especially uh difficult to move to the
day pharmacy a sharp decrease the number
of new age cases from 2019 to 2022
and we believe that there is uh is not a
same pattern across the country we
probably have very
market difference between uh sites in
biggest
cities and small cities and
undeveloped provisions and we have uh
heard from uh
colleagues from other cities and regions
that
this situation can be much more uh
uh
significantly affected by
the adherence the medical visit is uh
and uh probably
in different places of the country there
is different this situation
it means that we do not know yet the
impact of the hiv resistance because uh
there is nothing on that but probably
will be significant and will appear in
the next few months or next few years
next like this
and uh
as a sort of conclusion we can take from
this data
according to the official data the
address pattern to intent of our therapy
was not significantly exchanged
dependent
but
we believe that the increasingly duke
supply duration was important to
minimize additional
however missing medical visits were
clearly associated with the peaks of
convenience 19 pandemic especially in
the first year of the of it
and
today we have no way to measure the
impact of pandemic and consequent
increase in frequency or misinterest on
adherence
and on emergence of viral resistance
we believe that
we will need more investigation more
deeper investigation that international
level to
know exactly how was the impact of this
pandemic on the
all these markers of our hiv care and
especially specifically on the
units target for 2030.
thank you for your attention
so thank you so much um professor carlos
for that presentation and right now
we'll move to our second speaker um dr
olabanjo gonzalez
doctor is the associate director and
head of prevention and community
directorate at ap public health
initiatives ap and public health
initiative is a prefa implementing
partner in nigeria and in dr gonzalo's
role as the head of prevention and
community directorate he provides
technical and strategic leadership for
hiv program implementation activities
across several states on location in
nigeria and so right now i'll hand over
to
dr controller for his presentation
yeah uh thank you dr kobe and thank you
professor carlos for sharing the
perspective from brazil
i'll be sharing the
uh impact of kovid19 pandemic
on the
unh9595 in nigerian program experience
let's light this
i would like to
declare conflict of interest disclosure
that uh
i was given an
honorarium for this
so despite the kovi 19 pandemic nigerian
made progress across the unh 9595 gold
in 2018
nigeria was at 67 53 42 peace times
looking at the 95.95 and in the year
2020 we moved to ninety percent for the
first night c5 86 for the second and
72 for the top 95. so if you look at
this despite
the pandemic in the year 2019
and 2020 we made progress next slide
please
so
the covet 19 pandemic story in nigeria
the first case of kovite 19 pandemic
was on 27th february 2020 and within a
short period it spread across all states
in the country
as for 26 april 2022 nigeria has tested
over 5 million
with over 250 confirmed cases
and the case fatality rate in nigeria is
about 1.3
next slide please
with the advent of covenanting
versailles uh nigeria has
partially
vaccinated 20 percent of the eligible
client
and has fully vaccinated 13.3 percent as
of april 2024 2022
next slide please
the kovy 19 pandemic in nigeria
triggered massive contraction in client
volume in its facilities
and this also had an impact on the hiv
case finding and retention on treatment
if you look at the figure here this
australian experiences from two states
in nigeria
at the scare of kobe 19 in february 2020
there was a plunge in
the number of new cases identified for
hiv
and in the number of positives to
identify
and of course there were a
population-wide anxiety and concern and
there were structural lockdown in the
country in which
are restricted and even facilities we
are only offering emergency services
next slide please
however
what was the
experience and impact for house and
helping public health initiative uh we
are a pepper implementing partner
and currently
one in every five
people living with hiv in nigeria are
receiving care in our supported
facilities
next slide please
so looking at the first 95
in the year 2018 uh nigeria conducted
the national aids indicator and impact
survey
and that actually
brought to the fore
the current status of hiv infection in
nigeria and
how the program needs to move forward
and their com kovi 19 pandemic in 2019
uh for the first 95
there was a shift
to the community to deepen hiv case
finding
prior to this um more efforts were
concentrated in the facilities so if you
look in our program
you see a gradual increase in the
proportion of
hiv
testing done in the community
next slide
and this is showing
comparing the youth from the facility
testing
and the community and if you look at
when covered 19 was at this peak
a lot of efforts were in the community
and community was actually yielding
quite
a high number of
uh hiv positive uh
you can see that at starting time
we were at eight percent nine percent
positivity
however as since is up it do till down
to meet uh the facility
uh testing yielding numbers
next slide
so what strategies are
being implemented at the facility or in
the community
while the country is moving is
implementing risk-based testing using
the wrist transfusion tool and that has
really improved uh testing efficiency
and also improve
yield from testing so we are more
efficient in the use of resources then
we've also intensified index testing
both at the facility and the community
and the use of data
recently its map to target location of
active transmission to improve hiv case
detection
next line
now looking at the second 95
issues about retention and treatment uh
in our program
if we look at uh
a trend analysis as shown here between
october 2018 and september 2021
you can see that we had more people on
treatment uh living with uh hiv despite
the covey 19 pandemic
next slide
and one of the strategies to to keep
more people on treatment
is the multi-month dispensing uh
so this figure is showing
that as we move
in the during the pandemic there were
more
plhiv who are placed on six months drunk
that means they they have drugs they can
use for six months at all
and the impact of restriction in
movement
structural lockdown will have minimal
impact on them and as they are retained
on treatment and they're able to achieve
virus suppression
next like this
so for us to optimize retention
key strategies is to work with the
community with the network of people
living with hiv
then to implement
case management team structure
and to reduce interruption in treatment
uh
this has really worked then they of
course the differentiated service
delivery in which
people at the center of the services
they are receiving so services are taken
to people where it's convenient and and
this has helped them to be retained
in care
next slide please
now looking at the top 95
ensuring viral load coverage and
suppression
the covenant pandemic had impact on
commodity logistics and lab operations
the key issues were inter and intra
state movement restriction
there are also delay shipments of
commodities regions uh due to flight
destruction
commodities shortage due to production
caught by vendors
and this actually had impacts uh
on
after 95 they were stopped out of pcr
commodities and this they also prolong
turn around time for sample movement and
results return
which
also accumulation of
samples backlog of samples because there
are no reagents and commodity to process
them
and they also delay an assets of
engineers which to come out to sites to
resolve uh
equipment thoughts
or what are the interventions that we
have put in place uh
sample
routing to mega labs uh
results were returned using using korea
services and there was the activation of
the laboratory information management
system
which is an electronic method of
downloading results
at the facility so it results don't need
to move from the lab to the first
selection
next slide
and this intervention actually yielded
results that despite the kovy19 pandemic
in our program we can see
a progressive increase in environment
coverage and suppression
even during the pandemic if you look at
2019-2020
if you compare you can see there's a
steady progress
environment coverage and suppression and
at the end of q1
2022 we've achieved variable coverage
and suppression of 95 percent
nest slide place
so what are the strategies put in place
to achieve
95 percent parallel coverage and
suppression
one
we can liken it under this three
category the pre-tracking intervention
the tracking intervention and the
post-traumatic intervention the
pre-tracking
intervention has to do with education
educating the patients
and deploring viral champions as kids
keep us at the entry and exit points
then the
generating line listing of active
clients will require parallel bleeding
and the tracking interventions involve
using of peer the case management team
the facility tracking team
institution institutionalizing cluster
bleeding in actual rich communities so
that even bleeding for virality can be
done in the communities we don't
actually need to wait for them to come
to the facilities and the post-tracking
intervention
is the use of the
laboratory information management system
which has helped to reduce the
turnaround time
from results getting from the lab to the
facility
next slide
please so what are the key lessons like
uh
that relates uh to the impact of kovi 19
on hiv programming one we've learned
that integrating routine
fascination services into irt services
have helped to improve
vaccination coverage
and it does also help
to improve
hiv case identification
then that differentiates service
delivery is the way to go because this
has helped to improve patient platform
in terms of retention in terms of viral
coverage in terms of viral suppression
and the use of technology
phone call whatsapp group sms
has helped to improve patient monitoring
we've also learned that multi-month
dispensing is key
to improving retention and suppression
then for the 8th care workers who've
learned that the virtual platform is a
good tool to build capacity of x care
workers and that they coveted pandemic
has overall
improved
the standard safety precaution and
engine of edge facilities
and of our hca workers
next slide
this good
uh
results or mitigation of the impact of
government 19 on the un aids 95-95-95
was done in collaboration and support
from different stakeholders
the funding agency prefer the network of
people living with
hiv aids in nigeria
implementing partners like apen the
government of nigeria the community
itself global phone and of course we
need to thank the healthcare workers who
have worked tightly tirelessly during
this period to provide services
to
our patients
nestle
thank you so much
thank you so much um dr ogun scholar
um without further ado i will go ahead
and introduce our next speaker
our next speaker is mandisa dukashi
mendiza is the founder and director of
hiv survivors and partners network in
south africa
and for over 15 years she has worked in
the field of hiv program design
management and system strengthening
she is a u equals eu pioneer in south
africa and a co-founder of ue called new
africa forum we produce a movement that
is led by people living with hiv across
nine african countries and this is also
a member of several advisories of
several key advisorial boards on hiv
prevention and control and so we welcome
and visa to give us her presentation
um thank you so much ob
um
i want to declare that i received an
honorarium to be a speaker and i don't
have any conflict of interest
and i'll be presenting um
the overview is coveted impact on hiv
services human resource and
infrastructure and the uns 1990 progress
um i think um during the opening ob did
um highlight on what 1990 are and i'll
also talk about data
data before and after covet hiv drug
resistance and next slide please
um
the pandemic mainly impacted hiv
educational testing programs and the
provision of protection methods and
especially during lockdown because
people could not um travel to access
their services and that most of the
services happening in communities and in
south africa every provision was
generally maintained during the 2020
corporate 19 lockdown and what i think
what also helped is the educating or
decentralization of hiv services
especially arv's
provision and because people and
collected areas in communities they had
they did not have to go to facilities
but hiv testing which is mostly
community based home based and
it was severely affected and arv
initiation were heavily impacted as well
in other countries like kenya and
nigeria up to 50 people with hiv could
not have their arvs and supplies
next slide please
and when it comes to human resource
commodities and infrastructure health
facilities experienced death strategies
when facing the search of covert 19. so
the situation was further complicated by
staff absenteeism health workers were
very sick because of corporate because
as you know that there are first they
were first-line workers during that the
corporate 19 um
um pandemic and some had to come
quarantined because of exposure to the
virus and in total 67 percent of
facilities across africa were affected
and those sport checks that were done in
health facilities and
data proved that um 24 countries in
africa and only only 38 of her
facilities had protective material that
is mask disinfectant gloves and hand
sanitizers and across all health workers
and only 61 percent had sexual mass
remember those people that you're
talking about are front liners and
they're we're engaging with patients on
a daily basis and only eight percent of
facilities across africa could carry out
a covert 19 pcr test and 37 percent
could refer samples some countries had
to use
pr hiv pcr machines to test for profit
that is redirection of infrastructure
and commodities next slide please
um what was the impact um in the on the
1990 targets
and i think as i was saying that we all
know what the 1990 meant before corvette
and in the continent or um in africa is
there in southern africa and as of 2020
20.6 million people were living with hiv
just before corvette and out of the 20.6
million people with hiv
72 percent of those people had access or
were on arvs or antiretrovirals and
after 20.6 million people with hiv 65
had viral suppression i'm looking at the
numbers below um i'm overlooking the one
above because if you look at those above
you may think that we succeeded and
achieved but interpretation of those is
not looking at the total number of
people that are living with hiv that's
why i'm concentrating on the numbers
below next slide please
so what have what what was what was the
scenario or the picture before private
and after covert um according to paper
paper data hiv tests before covert the
quota was at 3.7 million and that number
decreased by close to a million after
coverage to 2.7 million and the
positivity rate per quarter before kobe
2 was it was 864 000. and after covert
it decreased by close to 60 000 um the
numbers of people that tested
positive for hiv air v initiation it was
89 percent we were close to achieving
the 90 targets this is um but
post coverage that decreased to by 60
and
to 60 percent the decrease of 30 percent
and imagine this is data that was
presented 80 21 we don't know what's the
issue and the situation now
so our resources that were used for hiv
that had to be redirected to covet this
other machine used for hiv parallel
testing and able to rapid establishment
of covet to piss out testing meaning a
lot of um you know activities or tests
that were supposed to be done for hiv
could not and gene sequences platforms
established for hiv and resistance
system were used for um variant
identification and clinical trial
infrastructure for hiv vaccines by voted
to undertake covert 19 by a vaccine
trials next slide please
so there was also a survey that was done
by human research a science research
council in south africa that um
discovered that 13 of people had no
access to their chronic medication
during lockdown and the rapid assessment
in zambia and in april 2020 just before
covert i think it was a month after it
was identified find out that 90 of
people with hiv attempting to get
fulfilled it was the time where you know
logged and i think it was in level five
those people could not get a refill of
their anti-retrovirals they could not
actually access some had a partial
refill of their treatment and the
government prioritized intervention to
control the spread of science of it and
less effort was put into ensuring
continued of other health services
including delivery of hiv services
in may 2020 just two months after
identification of corvette world
organization survey in 13 african
countries um discovered that there were
a lot of stock outs and especially with
the first line drugs risen being
including failure to supply
remember i think one of the speakers
mentioned that the flight restrictions
and you know and all that kind of thing
really affected this particular um
supply the next slide please
so you know i think there was there's a
lot of data that proves that a majority
or some people with hiv are developing
drug resistance and um this one in
particular i was conducted in south
africa in 2017 and discovered that more
than a quarter 27.4 of virally
unsuppressed and responding head viral
resistance and of hiv so now logged on
happened and we know there were a lot of
gaps in terms of treatment access and
all that and all some of people some
people could not have their viral load
done and a drug resistant testing could
not be done because infrastructure had
to be used for coverage so therefore
it's very clear that there will be more
number of people increasing and in
developing drug resistance so it is
critical that the government recover
plan
and close monitoring of development of
drug resistant hiv
should be a top priority and routine
development measurements should be um a
main focus efforts to increase access to
routine hiv drug resistant testing
should be increased this will enable um
this will enable more people
uh sorry like there was an a break in my
network this will enable more rapid
response to emerging resistant patterns
and prevent increase in acquired drugs
drug representation cases which were on
the rise even before covet next slide
please
um so this is my last line so una is
reported that covet 19 pandemic had
seriously impacted the aids response and
could um
disrupt it more i think it was before i
think the first year so a six-month
complete disruption in hiv treatment
could cause more than five hundred
thousand it is out there in the region
over the next year that is between 20 20
21 bringing the region back to 2008
mortality level even a 20
disruption could cause an additional
habit in 10 000 deaths so this is
something that you really really need to
focus on as the regime because you need
to mop up and look at them actually they
go down to assessing the impact of covet
19 and come up with
medication plans
and this is my last slide
um thank you so much for listening over
to uob
thank you so much mendez um so i will go
ahead and introduce our fourth speaker
our fourth speaker is dr cc
she is a public health specialist and
epidemiologist with over 29 years of
experiences in hiv aids care treatment
and research dr kittio is among the
pioneers of antiretroviral therapy
in south saharan africa from 1992
and she has been at the forefront of
scaling up care and treatment since
2003. dr kittier is currently the
executive director
of the
joint clinical research center in
kampala uganda and so at this time i
would hand over to dr c.c kiki
for her presentation
i will talk about the state and role of
hiv drug resistance testing for
surveillance
and patient management in uganda
and its relationship with achieving
epidemic control
in the country
this is my conflict of interest
disclosure
so the wake-up call to address hiv drug
resistance for patient management
especially in law and middle-income
countries
only came after the hiv drug resistance
hiv
world health organization report
in
2017
and in this report
six of the 11 countries that had
reported national hiv drug resistance
survey data
collected according to who guidelines
hard pre-treatment hiv drug resistance
equal to or above 10 percent
and uganda featured prominently
among these countries as can be shown
here
in blue
however high levels of hiv drug
resistance had already been detected in
uganda
as part of the pan-african studies to
evaluate resistance code named paisa
which were conducted across 13 clinical
sites in six african countries
starting from
2009.
so the highest hiv drug resistance rates
were seen in uganda
with in and out ti rates higher than
five percent
across three sites that participated in
this survey
and these are the high levels that were
shown
from the sites in in uganda
the same surveillance was done in the
pediatric populations at the same sites
as the adult surveillance
from 2010
and
these are the sites as shown here
and this uh surveillance recruited
317 pediatric patients
who had a viral load done every six
months
and similar to the adult population
pretreatment hiv drug resistance
to in and out ice as shown in yellow
here
was already above five percent
and in in ballet this was the town shown
in the previous slide which is near the
kenya border
the
resistance was even more than 10 percent
so uh the action
taken to address the high hiv drug
resistance to n and rtis
was the revised
world health organization
recommendations to use dotegravia best
regimens in first and second line arrt
regiments
and these are excepts from
the who guidelines
addressing the hiv drug resistance
at that time and now impacts directly
on the third 95 goal or target of unh
of having viral suppression
which in turn prevents
transmission of hiv
so uganda like all other countries is
working towards ending the hiv epidemic
by addressing many facets of the hiv
but
including controlling viral load and
hiv drug resistance
so uh
on the
left hand side
this graph shows uh that by 2020 how
uganda was doing
there's been a steady decline in new
infections
in aids related deaths and all cause
mortality
along people live
people living with hiv
on the right hand side this is the
projection that by 2020 if we continue
to
put all resources and efforts are better
aligned
by 2023
we
project to have hiv epidemic control
attained
and this is when new infections
are lower than all cause mortality among
people living with hiv
again the unh strategy to end the aids
epidemic includes the third 95 target or
viral suppression
and viral monitoring which we are doing
in the programs is to detect early
treatment failure
and also development of hiv drug
resistance
so uh despite kovid
19
in the last two years uganda has seen
steady improvement in both viral load
coverage
and viral load suppression
as at the same time we were seeing an
increase in the transition of patients
through dotecuria best regimens
as per the who
guidelines
this slide shows a snapshot
of copied 19 trends
in uganda from 2020.
the country had two lockdowns
and between the two lockdowns that just
total six months
out of the 15 months shown on this slide
it's inevitable
therefore
uh because this is about 40 percent of
the total time
shown on the graph it is inevitable that
there were possible disruptions in the
gains
made in the road map to ending the hiv
epidemic
which was fairly on course
and
this slide shows uh
that compared to the pre-pandemic
baseline
which is the red dotted line
we saw a decline in all categories of
patients enrolling on arrt as new
entrants
and uh
it can be seen from this slide that a
lot of effort
was being put
on patients who are already enrolled on
ert
so the numbers continued to
increase
even during 2020 2021 when we had
covered
because of the several strategies and
efforts
put into place
to ensure that patients access their
treatment even during lockdown
however
a decline in the children accessing art
was seen
and traditionally this is the age group
with the biggest problem of adherence
and possibility of developing hiv drug
resistance
so this slide shows
the
viral load tests done and also viral
load suppression
the viral load tests as you can see
fluctuated a lot during the past two
years
although viral load suppression among
those tested is seen to
increase however we don't know what is
happening to those patients we can't
reach
to perform a viral load
whether in lock down or not
again this slide
which is from pepfar
summarizes
sustained viral suppression at 96
percent with increasing numbers of
patients starting the autogravia
best regimens
and as shown in orange there is emphasis
and increasing multi-month dispensing
to prevent arrt interruptions
and therefore sustain viral road
suppression
so
while
the viral load suppression is high
we looked at hiv drug resistance prior
to the national
dolce graveyard rollout in 2018 to
establish a baseline of delta gravia
resistance and continue to monitor
resistance
so that we can inform
the programs
and among the arat naive patients as
seen on the upper graph
the first line pha and first line
failures
on the lower graph we did not see
any resistance to the to the dotergravia
and this work was done in 2018.
all the green uh
buzz shows
that these patients were susceptible
to deuterogravia
[Music]
in the in the same study
we
also did not see any resistance to dual
telegraphia in patients failing second
line art
as all of them were on uh
protease inhibitors based art
so patients who are failing on
intergrace based regimen and at the time
we were using rautigravia
already showed
uh
high levels
of
resistance
and cross resistance actually to other
um integrals inhibitors which were not
using at the time like dortegravia
yeah
so um this slide
is data from a more recent work actually
done in 2022
after the rollout of the autogravia
and we see we had uh
participants with a wide range
of
edges
and in green patients had been on
treatment for varied time periods
and then from this graph we saw that we
had adolescents and children failing on
first line
we had patients failing on second line
and also patients were failing
on third line
so uh as per the indication on the
previous slide for testing
uh this drug resistance surveillance
data is also used for patient management
so from this graph
we see that we have a fairly high level
of resistance through autogravia which
has been used for some time now
in the country especially for patients
who need headline
and
that resistance
also shows
that there is cross-resistance to
cabotegravia and victor gravia
which have not been used in the country
except
under research settings and the numbers
that have taken it are very small
however we see that resistance to
dotergravia is still low despite the
rollout
but we need to continue
to do surveillance and so that we can
inform our policy and also the program
so we are continuing to do hiv drug
resistance surveillance and two studies
are planned
uh one of them is for patients on the
autogravia who are failing with a viral
load above a thousand copies
and this work is going to be done at the
uvri
while we are also looking at another
study of patients failing on the
ethographia but with low level viremia
of 200 to 999
copies per ml
and the goal is to maintain the
ultegravia durability following the high
pre-drug
pre-drug resistance
that the country experienced within an
ltis
but also to detect drug resistance
mutations to deltagravia
as early as possible and inform
the arrt
program
so in summary
there is evidence of increasing hiv drug
resistance to dotegravia from 2018
to present
as the drug is being scaled up for first
and second line treatment
although this resistance
is still low at the
moment this
may affect gains made in hiv programming
even during covet 19 epidemic
so preventing
and then ongoing monitoring and
responding to this hiv drug resistance
is critical to maintaining the current
achievements especially viral
suppression
improving patient outcomes and
guaranteeing
long-term sustainability of care and
treatment programs
thank you for listening to me
um
so thank you so much dr cece for your
presentation and we will um switch over
right now to our panel discussion
where we would engage all the speakers
and talk a little bit more dive deeper
into some of their presentations and
some of the findings that they
talked about
and so
i guess for the first question in the
panel discussion we all talked about a
lot of practices that were implemented
in the different countries um to help
counter the effect of kobe 19 and some
people had great success so amongst all
the things that we talked about if we
have to look beyond covet into things
that we can retain
in this country beyond covid what would
be your top
one or two things one or two
things that were implemented in your
country that we would say we can retain
and would be sustainable beyond coded
and so i will start from dr ogunschala
uh thank you dr obi for that question
but what i would say is that we need to
keep the tempo
in implementing
differentiated service delivery
because
we need to
put people at the center of the services
they they need
one car does not fit all
so people are
have very various needs various
challenges
so when we tailor our services to them
like we did in rank of 19
and they make mutual apples to between
people living with hiv in care
achieve environmental coverage and
suppression
so
health care worker led group community
air to refuel group
you know community pharmacy group
look up all the multi-month dispensing
these are key things that we've learned
that and i think we should keep on
within them expand them as one of the
key lessons from kobe 19 pandemic
thank you so much yourself so i really
like the fact that you talked about
differentiated service delivery so
focusing on people and what they need um
one of the things that professor carlos
brought up was um
he he talked about population so he
there was um something about women being
lost to follow-ups um differentially
than other populations he also talked
about regional differences and so i
guess i will ask this question to
professor um carlos about how to
actually address this inequality that we
see in different subpopulations and
different um
regions and
just thinking through beyond coded what
we've done before kovis is probably not
enough if we want to achieve the 2030 um
goals that we've set up too so what can
we do in addition to actually reach all
the sub-populations and populations that
are experiencing inequality in hiv care
and treatment
uh i believe the the the main one of the
main challenges in uh managing the the
hiv epidemic not only in brazil but in
several countries similar
characteristics is
access
and when we talk about access access to
prevention especially
and uh in this specific point
women are
most vulnerable than men in general and
in brazil at least we
we see a
very uh patriarchal society and uh
sometimes women have no uh
no right access it's not providing a
good access to health care and for uh
care in general
we in you know a few years ago we we
look at the number of people women
pregnant women
arriving on us
health care service for
with hiv and 25 of them in our state
was
late presenters over 20
32
weeks of gestation it means
probably no anti-natal care no access to
health care in general it uh i believe
that the hiv
epidemic affecting a disproportionate
way
women and men in brazil and
many other
places
but here especially specifically
i believe
to provide
equal access without many barriers that
they face in the
uh when they look for uh
health care would be the main challenge
for our authorities
and uh i believe that the decreasing the
number of the proportion of women with
viral suppression
is different from women that dislike
that i show them that
it it means
there is
probably many barriers we have to tackle
in order to provide a
proper treatment for women and
access to terror
can you speak a little bit more about
what can be done to actually achieve
access for
regions that are now um
different uh differentially um affected
by hiv as well as you know the added
impact of poverty that you know we
haven't yet seen and we will probably
see them
yes brazil is a
continental country it's a
very large country with very
clear disparities if you if you go to
the south region we have a very
developed society with access to many
services that in the north northeastern
region
we will let
us the same pattern of service
so in the north with an amazon vision
it's very very difficult to have a
proper healthcare
the access to health services are very
difficult there is no road most of the
transportation is by rivers and uh
sometimes the next
health care service is about five hours
of votes
so by voting
it's a completely different if you go to
the the develop
region of the country so
it's a big challenge because it was a a
consequence of
decades of differential approach for
development of these areas
so this kind of inequality will be hard
to to fight because it
probably would take
longer than
just providing uh
on heterovirus drugs
testing for hiv and that so covida
show well that uh
the disproportion between the the access
to care in the developer regions of the
country and the underdeveloped regions
like amazon region where the mortality
rate was
much higher than the other areas so
that's a big problem and uh i did not
see a
easy solution in the short term probably
would take decades to solve this complex
situation
so i hear i hear a lot of
multi-dimensional problems that you know
need to be addressed even beyond health
care like we need to look beyond health
care to other to work in collaboration
with other ministries and other partners
to actually address this problem of
access regional disparities and access
um so i will just ask my next question
to mandusa um talking thinking through
what the government
makes available melisa mentioned about
how corvis
took over
hiv
technologies that were available for
example um pcr machines were now being
used for copies and survival loads and
all that and so now that we've
transitioned well we're emerging our
transition in out of kobe we haven't
fully transitioned but we're coming out
of kobe's there's been so much
investment in kobe so much investment in
technologies on the ground so much
investment in training and all and so
melissa i guess the question to you is
how can we leverage what has been
invested and use it to advance hiv care
and treatment in countries
i believe over and above um the
resources that you are talking about
and covert has taught uh taught us
communities and decision makers
importance of collaboration and and
working together focused and that alone
it's something that we really need to
look into when we have a similar goal
because
everyone else in communities and and
businesses and we're looking and working
forward
towards ending the you know the corvette
19 which is something that you really
need to learn um in in in terms of
focusing on end resources um you know
there's a lot of infrastructure
equipment that um
somehow was
procured to respond to covet and now
that we really am seeing that the covet
19 subsiding those resources will
definitely remain behind covet will end
eventually the resources will remain
behind and could be used and for hiv
response and you know i think one one
critical thing that we saw as the as the
origin in africa is the the impact or
the the capacity that the region has in
terms of resource mobilization because
we managed to actually mobilize
resources within a short period of time
which is financial resources which
someone somehow most of african
countries they were struggling to and
testing very low because of it was said
to be expensive and but we managed to
actually have resources to actually look
into how do we
support covet which is actually a skill
that we never knew that we have as the
reaching and um i think last lastly and
the infrastructure
that especially with um the skill that
we actually managed as the regime to
actually prove that we have because we
had to manage to have um covet 19
vaccines and produced locally you know
so we have scientists and they remember
one news and the variant um some somehow
i heard that south africa was one of the
countries that identified the one of the
coveted varieties which means we've got
resources in the country that we the
skilled expertise that we had as the
country and the region that we never had
so there is a lot that we can learn and
actually leverage on from the covered 19
lessons
thank you thank you mandy that dr cece i
will ask you the same question about
what uganda has learnt from the kovis 19
pandemic and what can be what is going
to be kept or sustained after coverage
in the hiv care and treatment
work
thank you obe
i think
the silver lining on kovid
was to do things differently to achieve
the same results
and uh
we had to make sure we reached all the
patients
and i think uh
dr ola banjo has already talked about
the patient-centered
strategies which were there
but maybe they were not as intensive as
we had to make them to make sure that
patients get their drugs
and there were many strategies uh
community distribution points
actually delivering drug using
motorbikes
to patients
and uh also knowing that how can we do
um telemedicine in a way
so i think uh these strategies
we need to
keep
the intensity and not stop because kovid
is sort of going down if we are to reach
the epidemic control that we are talking
about
um
my colleague there has talked about
platforms for testing
initially
tests became
they were so expensive and our
governments were not able to test
everybody because it was over 60 dollars
yet they had to open borders and you
know trade and economies had to sort of
be sustained even when we had lockdowns
and we had to modify the platforms that
we had to do testing but we also had to
think very differently
and for uganda this is the
first time that there was major funding
from government
to scientists
to
provide solutions to covid
and so we have groups that started to
work on uh coveted vaccines but this is
not just covet vaccines
now you have the resources you have the
know-how you have the infrastructure
and you can work on vaccines for other
diseases including emerging diseases
we had to start working on diagnostics
and our institution has developed a
diagnostic for poverty
initially we were using the platform
that we used for viral load
it has very low throughput
very high tech
removed from the population now we
we have developed a clause to point of
care
platform
but this platform
even now as cove it goes down we know
that we can use the platform for other
for other diseases because the
system
or the processes are the same you just
change the primers
for the uh disease that you are looking
at
we had
local production
of
masks
sanitizers
and
i think
this
will also help our economies
and we we had to do this because we
couldn't first of all we couldn't get
vaccines initially
every country that had their vaccines it
was for their population so i think this
is an eye-opener that
yes you have to use your brain which we
have
you have to um
put in place infrastructure
and please look at research funded by
our local
governments
and this research is not necessarily for
covered but it also actually
feeds into hiv
and we look around and we do all this
testing
and where do we get all the kids for hiv
testing
40 40 years after the beginning of the
epidemic we import them
so why can't we make our own i think
this was really an eye opener
and uh these are the things that remain
not to just benefit covet but benefit
hiv
and now right now we are starting to
roll out point of care viral testing
before we had centralized testing so we
then covered when
there were issues with transport
and transporting samples to the
centralized place
now when we look at okay we can do even
when we take drugs to community
we can do point of care viral load
testing
in their communities
because these are strategies that we
have started to accelerate and we should
keep the accelerator on
because this is what will also help us
with our control of the hiv clinic
thank you so much dr cc so i would um
you talked about point of care testing
which i really like because i think
mandisha mentioned how the connection
between variable suppression and hiv
drug resistance and so
right now we're seeing that a lot of
countries are rolling out the
integrase structures withstands um
anterior trivial sorry integrated drugs
um the the new line of interiors drugs
for hiv treatment and we see that at
least for those drugs right now there's
very low levels of resistance into any
around the world and so how can we
ensure that those jobs actually stay
active
okay um
we have now we've rolled out
in many low and middle-income countries
uh
dr gravy are all intergrace based
arrt for first and second line
and uh really the reason many people
looked at even uh the recommendations
came out was because there was high
barrier to development of resistance to
the autogravia
it was relatively safe
except for the scale we got about
neurotuba defects in in new bonds
um but it's well tolerated as uh as a
drug
and so um
in uganda we we like nigeria we continue
to see
continued viral load suppression in
those who are tested
and we but we missed many people for
testing
those who are tested we continue to see
very low suppression
but also there was
at the same time an increase
in the patients that were being enrolled
onto adult tegrity or integrase based
uh ert both for first line and second
line
and uh the survey that we have done or
the data that we have collected and this
is data that is taken from
patients in care
it's used both for surveillance but also
for managing the patients
we are still seeing very low levels of
the autogravia resistance
this could be due to uh there may have
been breaks
in uh
in patients taking the drugs but
this drug maybe is very
robust
and for now
we have seen no resistance
but we need to continue the monitoring i
think the priority for any government in
2020 2021 was not going to do
drug resistance surveys
and
so now as we come out of covid we need
to continue to monitor but the best way
to prevent our resistance is adherence
so take the drugs to the patient and
make sure they check it that is the best
prevention
don't have a stock-outs
uh but is the autograph you're more
forgiving if you have some stock out
or if you don't take your drugs as you
should
um i don't know the exact answer maybe
it is more forgiving
but in the long term
we need to continue as
governments as
ministries of health as program people
we need to continue
monitoring and doing surveillance for
drug resistance because we do not want
to lose this beautiful drug
and um
we had to change in 2018 because of very
high levels of pre-treatment drug
resistance
we have we need to sustain and maintain
this drug we don't want to lose it
so programs need to monitor but at the
same time put in place
uh strategies to prevent
things that will lead to drug resistance
like um
adherence is very critical
and
of course some of the reasons that
we have breaks in treatment have to do
with programs if you don't have the
drugs in the clinic then patients won't
go for them if you have covered and
patients cannot go to the clinic but you
cannot also take drugs to them where
they are
then there is a break
but also the patients the beautiful um
this it's just one tablet a day at least
for patients on first time and second
line so it's very convenient
and i think better adherence because of
also
less side effects
uh
but we have to continue monitoring we do
not want to go back to a state where now
we have to look for another alternative
drug
i'm gonna ask a question about what did
not work well so we talked about what
works well for countries
and so um maybe i will ask professor
carlos what did not work well what
should we drop what shouldn't we
continue
well
what not to do
this is a
the first point is
not to allow
barriers for
patients to reach the
health care services which means to
provide some conditions or
in our situation for instance in my my
cities are is not a
riches here in the country
the middle income but terminal law
development region
we have many patients that did could not
come to
medical visit or to take the refugee
artery field even the pandemic because
they have no money to pay for
transportation
so
it is
very very simple because uh it costs
about two dollars to go and come back
home but
it's crucial for the patient if you have
no money to move to the health care
service to take your medication
how can i
ask the patient to take properly the
daily drugs
so i believe
do not forget
that you said
in my first
response you said that
what should be the point we need to
solve
one of the points i guess is not to look
only for the infrastructure but for the
special needs of the patient the
specific needs
food safety
transportation conditions we have a
program that provides free access to
a public transportation for hiv patients
but it's very bureaucratical to get the
idea
the authorization to use the the service
and some patients do not know that
they have the right to
travel without paying for
so i i believe that
these barriers could be uh
surpassing if you have a clear political
willingness to provide
a great access and wide access for
this kind of patient for the health
service in general
i believe that
the main is
the main policies are focused on
providing
treatment providing uh testing
providing uh
referral centers
they are essential but they they are not
the only important thing when we look at
the hiv
patient especially because this part of
the population
usually is a
poor population without access to
education to minimal rights so
i guess do not
if do not forget
forgetting that this specific point
would be
an important action to improve the
access and the outcomes of this
population in general because
we have free of cost at hydrovirus
therapy we have a free of cost hiv
testing viral vote cd4 count genotype
everything is free for this patient but
sometimes
there's more
lacking point
missing point that
is
how to move in the city long distance
and
getting the minimum
safety support for food support
so
i believe don't forget these minimal
things but they are crucial to where the
uh
good success
in facing the any epidemic not not only
aids but any other that can that affect
our country and many others
thank you so much um dr khaled so people
sent that care is a big message that
we're here in here today
so focus on what people need
and you know don't
like um prof dr
was saying that not all cops feed
everyone and so um lisa i would like you
to talk about
your experience as a person who's
thriving
with hiv you're you're
you're an example to the world and you
know how are you
um pushing forward this idea of
people-centered care through your work
and you know uh just a brief um talk
about what you're doing
to facilitate this and you know how
you're working and really if you have to
give a message
to governments and to people working in
the states what would it be
um thank you so much aubry and i think
for for the past 40 years hiv services
has been um provider centered
and that's one of the reasons why and
we're not seeing that we're not ripping
the fruits that we're supposed to we
we're doing we're not doing bad
but at the same time
services programs are decided for they
are not decided with people with hiv and
for many years i think we all know about
the cheaper principle greater
involvement with people with hiv or many
food involvement of people with hiv i
think for me
i'm being
here 20 years later after my diagnosis
is because i've been meaningfully
involved in my care i've been taking
decision i've known what is good for me
what is not good for me i know when to
remind blast to be taken i know when to
remind my clinician to actually give me
my results back so it's it's about
people and taking a center
responsibility and leading their lives
because
we cannot run away from the fact that um
tunisians are decided for and people
with hiv and they are matured people
they are responsible people government
should trust people with their own care
don't decide for people it's okay
because clinicians and government know
more most of the time but the reasons
they know more is because they are not
sharing information with people and
changing treatment without telling a
person and you know as a clinician for
instance in south africa there was a
data that was just published recently
and that there is an i think it's in
most african countries of course that
very load testing the very load uptake
is poor because and we're depending on
clinicians to decide when but a lot must
be done and we decide on clinicians to
know and remember when viral laws are
done and in africa one clinician has a
queue of 50 clients and while while they
are busy consulting with this particular
client
they are called outside for emergency
when they come back at their hub hazard
they can't even remember that they're
supposed to take my viral load so what i
normally advise clinicians and program
managers is let the client know if you
are testing me today tell me when the
viral load will be used 16 august we are
taking overload i'm the one that should
be looking forward to the 16th of august
and i should know the importance of
taking treatment because also what i'm
noticing
is that there is more on quantity over
quality time is not spent with clients
to explain the benefits of treatment
that's why we we're seeing a number of
clients and you know not attending to
treatment we're losing a lot of clients
and the money that we're spending in
procuring drugs is not actually um
giving us what we're supposed to getting
that's why as the region and probably
most of the countries we could not
achieve the second night it's because
some clients they don't know the value
of taking treatment time is not spent
with client and that's a critical time
when the client has just been diagnosed
i don't think i would be here if i never
um spoke and i never had the quality of
hiv testing that i had after being
diagnosed and now i know the value of my
treatment and i know the value to myself
and i know that value in preventing
transmission hiv to my children and to
my husband i'm married i'm married to an
hiv negative
husband and we've got two beautiful hiv
negative daughters because i know the
value of me taking treatment and of me
protecting transmission or transmitting
hiv to my family which is something that
should be actually translated on be
communicated to all hiv positive clients
and i don't think we'll be sitting here
now and to you know pointing fingers at
the certain government and that facility
or health facility did not achieve this
and that it's not about clinicians it's
about clients let's trust clients who
take responsibility and be at the center
of their care and look at whether we'll
be achieving and i can assure you come
2025 when you have where to measure the
95 95 95. if you can do what the bill
all the speakers are saying patient
centered care engaging patient and let
people with hiv to be at the center by
2025 i can assure you that you will
achieve better results with that
thank you so much mandisa thank you so
so much for that
so thank you so much to all our
speakers today
we're very grateful for your time
and all the discussions we had today we
will try and put together
just a compendium of everything that we
have said especially our recommendations
and it will be available for people on
requests and so um as we end today we
really want to say thank you on behalf
of them official scientific and on
behalf of all the groups that we've
worked with tirelessly to put us
together so thank you and we will see
you again hopefully soon please reach
out for questions
for our audience to reach out we'll have
an email and you can go to our booth at
the conference
if you have questions as well thank you
you